bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france
partir ou éviter l' escalade est-ce que
l'argumentation de joe biden est
convaincant le président américain qui
fait adressé à ses concitoyens en cet
hiver
merci d'avoir invité d'abord un mot sur
dubaï d'un jogging ne cesse pas de se
féliciter de au travail qui a été fait
or on sait très bien que depuis dix ans
on savait que les actions qui ont été
faites n'était pas à hauteur guédé
attendu des attendus et que au nom donc
on ne fait pas un et l'agression
militaire avant de penser à ce qui reste
surtout lorsque le nombre est très
important et ceux qui vont gouverner ce
sont des personnes avec lesquelles on ne
peut pas négocier et qu'on n'est pas
arrivé à négocier parce que jamais
qu'ils ont tenu la parole donc pour moi
et c'est un échec qui est plus grande
que l'échec du vietnam et que quelques
informations qu'on a
des bases militaires où il y à des
afghans qui ont eu la chance d'être au
d'être accueillis aux états unis
laissent leur situation est
catastrophique a catastrophique parce
que ils se ressemblent maintenant au
numéro et non pas des êtres humains qui
doivent être pris en compte prise en
charge
aucun bus psychologie ces gens là ils
ont perdu tout donc on peut pas du tout
du tout du tout considérer que c'est un
c'est une victoire et qu'on n'avait pas
le choix il ya dix ans il y avait tous
les indicateurs qui le montrait qu est
ce qui était en train de faire sur le
terrain n'était pas
nous n'allez pas avoir les résultats
escomptés notamment au niveau rural où
il y avait 80 % de population qui est
toute cette aide n'était pas arrivé et
qu'elle est les talibans avaient déjà
commencé à exercer sur ces régions et
qu'elle est allée au jamais quitter
l'afghanistan
alors c'est vrai qu'on parle beaucoup
finalement de l'enlisement militaire sur
le terrain il ya aussi un enlisement
peut-être voir une déroute diplomatique
afin de négocier avec les talibans qu'en
pensez vous
alors aujourd'hui la situation des
talibans et la chose suivante il était
même pas cent mille donc 100 milles mais
même si on prend lâche le chiffre au
maximum le 100 milles qu'ils sont en
train prendre en otage 35 millions
arcand c'est quelque chose qui est
incroyable et qu'il ne se justifie pas
et des courbettes diplomatie pour
accepter pour dire on veut venir pour
les humanitaires ont d'avenir pour être
économique et setra de commencer à
négocier avec les talibans
les talibans sont ceux qui nous sorte
que des écoles coraniques je dis pas il
y en a pas quelques-uns qui ont été bien
éduqué abordés par les américains pour
bien négocier à doha et que mettre en
place la stratégie qu'ils font mais ce
sont des gens qui ne savent pas gérer
qui ne savent pas gouverner à part avec
la violence ils n'ont pas la taille zéro
bien justement on attend maintenant la
formation d'un gouvernement taliban est
ce que ces talibans sont suffisamment
unis pour y parvenir
les talibans ceux qui ont été à doha ne
sont pas nécessairement ceux qui sont
sur le terrain et qui ont été vite vécu
depuis les les écoles coraniques au
pakistan jusqu'à alors arrivé dans les
petits villages un peu partout ce sont
pas les mêmes et les messages ne sont
pas les mêmes du tout vu les violences
qui continuent sur le terrain malgré
toutes ces bonnes paroles qui est en
train se donnait pas
dans le chargé de communication qu'ils
disent et écouter on n'est pas comme
avant et reconnaissez vous nous
reconnaissons donc il faut que nouveau
la communauté internationale nous sont
l'iso pas avec une nouvelle erreur
et ça va durer vingt ans on va on va
éduquer les talibans pour qu'ils soient
plus
violentes comme comme ils sont et qu'ils
y at-il de diamants des personnes
respectables sauf si on peut imaginer
sauf si on peut imaginer qu'il a des
pakistanais qui a des pakistanais les
messages où était à l'intérieur du pays
largement diffusée il ya des ingénieurs
il y à des personnes savons qu'ils
peuvent venir en afghanistan pour aider
le gouvernement pour gouverner et c'est
dans cet ordre là l'afghanistan ne
devienne pas un état alexis à des côtes
d'oman officieusement
au pakistan
justement parlez du pakistan le chef de
la diplomatie heiko maas on l'a entendu
et effectue une tournée dans la région
et c'est s'est entretenu et que
notamment le chef de la diplomatie
pakistanaise ce dernier lui affirme qu
on pas vraiment faire confiance aux
taliban et on voit que la communauté
internationale elle se tourne finalement
vers les pays voisins c'est le cas aussi
de l'union européenne pour être tentés
de sortir l'aghanistan de la crise est
ce que les pays limitrophes ont
réellement
suffisamment de poids et ont les moyens
de changer la donne
les pays et mitrow ils ont peur que ceux
ci ça fasse une tâche dans leur propre
pays qui sont par ailleurs fragile donc
ça c'est une chose moi le discours de
madame qui dit on va créer des maisons
sauf pour les femmes etc etc moi je
pense que ça montre un décalage total
par rapport à ceux qui hélas vers
l'afghanistan aujourd'hui l'état libre
ont demandé aux femmes ont demandé aux
femmes de rester chez elle de ne pas
sortir notamment les jeunes parce que
les talibans ne savent pas quoi faire
avec les femmes dont le tout le sens de
carmes c'est à dire tous ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui dans les rues etc ne savent
plus quoi faire avec les femmes donc les
femmes
ont leur a donné des outils on leur a
donné des espoirs et et font partie
intégrante de ce qu'il faut qui ont fait
tourner le pays maintenant dans la sauce
doté sa femme là qu'ils ont une porte
immense de talibans et qui les talibans
ne savent pas comment se comporter avec
les femmes vous pensez qu'on peut faire
tourner ce pays en mettant à côté les
femmes non c'est ça me paraît encore un
voeu pieux et quelque sorte on a entre à
s'excuser d'avoir travaillé à cette
population merci beaucoup à vous à fine
et robiolle d'avoir répondu à nos
questions directes je rappelle que vous
êtes chargé de cours à l'essec aussi
merci de teyran et kaboul
vice-présidente également du club france
organisme